les policiers n'ont qu'une seule
solution attendre et c'est par pur
hasard que quelques semaines plus tard
l'affaire va rebondir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Carpentras le 11 décembre 2003 il est
presque 17 heures
au sud de la ville le centre commercial
du terradou se remplit peu à peu
Marie-Claude Bressy est venue acheter
son pain et elle est intriguée par une
étrange saine au milieu du parking
au moment où je fais pour garer
j'aperçois une personne un homme
qui s'avance dans ma direction et mais
quelque chose de bizarre il a une
cagoule une cagoule et pas seulement
et je vois
une arme au bout de sa main l'homme
tient un pistolet avance tranquillement
entre les voitures
Marie-Claude l'observe incrédule
lorsqu'il arrive près de ma voiture
il s'arrête son bras se lève
une première détonation retentit
devant sa boulangerie René bagnoles et
surpris par le coup de feu
la personne qui avait tirée Marc Antonin
[Musique]
et une deuxième détonation par
un homme est à terre touché dans le dos
Marie-Claude se précipite à son secours
le boulanger la rejoint
je pars je pars après le après le tueur
le cagoulé tout le monde commence à
crier non non mais il faut pas y aller
il est armé c'est dangereux ne c'est
pour de vrai arrêter
au bout d'une centaine de mètres
Marie-Claude victime d'un point de côté
prend sou d'un conscience du danger
j'ai peur
je réalise d'un coup
que peut-être il peut se retourner et me
mettre une balle à moi et je le laisse
je le laisse courir il m'échappe
[Musique]
sur le parking au chevet de la victime
le boulanger prévient les secours
[Musique]
quelques minutes plus tard bon tout le
monde arrive et puis là bon
les constatent que la personne est
décédée
au milieu du parking du petit centre
commercial les témoins sont sous le choc
on était en train de vivre un meurtre
ça dépassait toutes les réalités qu'on
pouvait imaginer
sur place les policiers de Carpentras
sécurisent la zone et font les premières
constatations autour du cadavre
un trou de l'omoplate gauche
le tireur
l'atteint dans le dos
la victime est plutôt âgée elle n'a
aucun papier sur elle qui est cet homme
qui vient de se faire abattre pour
l'heure impossible de le savoir les
policiers est sur place dans ce parking
ont très peu d'éléments ils ont un
cadavre un cadavre X il ne connaissent
pas l'identité de ce cadavre le monsieur
la victime se nomme d'une soixantaine
d'années on a rien on le connaît pas
c'est pas un notable c'est pas quelqu'un
de
c'est pas quelqu'un de Carpentras priori
sans identité impossible de comprendre
pourquoi cet homme a été assassiné et
surtout par qui la scène de crime est
passée au peigne fin et les témoins sont
entendus a commencé par Marie-Claude
Bressy le tueur elle s'en souvient bien
et elle peut même le décrire aux
policiers
il est grand c'est un grand un grand
jeune le jeune il a une allure
athlétique
mince trimestre il a il a un blouson
beige clair couleur mastic bien habillé
propre l'homme était cagoulé mais
Marie-Claude a pu croiser son regard
je vois bien ses yeux parce que
parce que ce regard
est fixe des yeux froids un regard foncé
c'est son calme qui me fait le plus
impression
[Musique]
il est fixé sur sa cible rien ne peut le
distraire
lorsque je crie
qu'est ce que vous avez fait que
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il ne me regarde pas
le deuxième témoin René Bagnol le
boulanger pense avoir vu le tueur un
quart d'heure avant le meurtre il
portait le même blouson que l'assassin
et détails à ce moment il n'avait pas
encore de cagoule le boulanger ne peut
pas le décrire de façon précise mais il
a vu son visage
tu vois
d'abord rentrer l'individu dans la
galerie terradou un petit peu dissimulé
mais sans plus
[Musique]
clair un bonnet assez impossé sur les
oreilles
et après il a vu ressortir il sait que
c'est le même et là il a vu avec une
cagoule
le tueur a ensuite emboîté le pas à la
victime jusqu'à sa voiture
ce témoignage là indique
que l'individu attendait sa victime
c'est pas un coup de feu tiré comme ça
sur une personne au hasard
au milieu du parking les techniciens de
la police scientifique finissent leur
relevé et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que les indices sont maigres
il ne trouve rien sur la scène de crime
il n'y a pas l'ombre d'une trace d'un
élément qui peut intéresser dans lequel
finalement c'est en interrogeant les
commerçants de la galerie commerciale
que les policiers vont trouver un
nouveau témoin
tout au fond de la galerie il y a une
boutique un peu particulière qui est en
réalité un sex-shop qui s'appelle
fantasme
la victime venait d'elle de ce section
un seul moyen de le savoir
[Musique]
et donc ils vont aller interroger le
gérant du sexe shop pour savoir si
leur mort leur cadavres sortaient de
cette boutique
gif effectivement il venait assez
régulièrement à des heures relativement
régulières des jours assez précis le
mardi le jeudi c'était un homme bon
évidemment discret souriant gentil
mais il y a un problème le gérant ne
connaît pas le nom de ce client régulier
et pour cause la victime payée toujours
en espèces
généralement dans ces endroits là on se
passe sa carte d'identité
mais il l'a déjà vu et il sait que la
victime qui était tendue sur le parking
atteint mortellement est un de ses
clients
les policiers ne connaissent toujours
pas l'identité de la victime mais le
gérant va tout de même le rapporter une
aide précieuse juste avant le meurtre il
a remarqué quelque chose d'étrange sur
sa caméra de surveillance d'après lui un
homme faisait les 100 pas devant le sex
shop et s'il s'agissait du tueur
il a une petite caméra qui filme et à
cette vidéo là il voit une paire de
baskets
il voit juste une paire de baskets donc
il se dit qu'effectivement
il y avait quelqu'un au fond de la
galerie
si c'est bien l'assassin que montre la
vidéo il est évident que l'homme a pris
soin d'éviter qu'on filme son visage la
victime serait-elle tombée dans un
guet-apens pour le savoir les policiers
ont besoin de déterminer l'identité de
l'homme abattu et pour ça il possède
peut-être une aide de taille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la voiture dans laquelle la
victime allait monter les policiers
fouillent le véhicule mais ne découvre
pas de carte grise
ils font alors une simple recherche
ils ont une plaque d'immatriculation
qu'ils vont s'empresser de faire
identifier et cette plaque
d'immatriculation donne un nom et une
adresse le nom c'est Guy pourriel il est
âgé de 72 ans et il habite à Cavaillon
Guy pourriez est-il l'homme assassiné
rien ne permet de l'affirmer encore avec
certitude la voiture a très bien pu être
prêtée ou volée
pour en avoir le cœur net dans la soirée
les policiers se rendent chez le
propriétaire du véhicule et c'est sa
femme Michel qui leur ouvre la porte on
vient lui demander comment établir son
mari comment et sa voiture décrivait la
voiture etc et elle donne le signalement
effectivement de du véhicule et de des
vêtements de son mari et à ce moment-là
la police la conviction donc c'est bien
monsieur pourrielle qui a été assassiné
et l'informe que son mari est décédé
effondré la veuve suit les policiers
pour identifier le corps elle ne sait
pas que cette affaire va vite devenir
l'un des faits divers les plus
retentissants de la région
dès le lendemain le meurtre de Guy
pourriel s'étale à la une des journaux
quand on apprend que un meurtre a eu
lieu à la sortie du sex shop de
Carpentras c'est tout de suite forcément
quelque chose de très particulier
c'est pas une boulangerie c'est pas une
banque c'est pas c'est pas un bar quoi
c'est injection
serait-il victime d'un meurtre lié à
l'univers du sexe pour le savoir les
enquêteurs se concentrent sur leur
victime qui était réellement cet homme
et surtout qui lui en voulait autant
pour l'exécuter de deux balles dans le
dos en plein jour
sa vie et passer au crible
tout est bon à prendre au départ surtout
dans une affaire comme celle-ci où on a
rien on fait ce qu'on appelle un
environnement de la victime
environnement familiale environnement
professionnel si a lieu
mais dès les premières auditions les
enquêteurs dressent le portrait d'un
homme a priori sans histoire
son casier judiciaire et rigoureusement
vierge il a exercé pendant longtemps la
profession de garagiste il avait une
concession Mercedes
à Cavaillon il est d'origine parisienne
il mène une vie tranquille sa famille le
décrit comme quelqu'un de
de paisible d'un paisible retraité qui
va qui passionné par la pêche il va très
très régulièrement il a peut-être eu un
passé un peu plus une mutueux la garder
Indochine le rugby mais aujourd'hui
c'est un gentil retraité absolument rien
dans la vie de monsieur pourrielle ne
pouvait laisser penser qu'il serait un
jour exécuté de cette manière là
pourtant on poursuivant leurs
investigations les hommes de la police
judiciaire d'Avignon découvrent que Guy
pourriel n'était peut-être pas qu'un
gentil retraité l'homme sans porter
rapidement
c'est un monsieur qui avait
certainement un très bon fond mais qui
avait une manière de s'exprimer un peu
brutal et qui donc en rajouter un petit
peu dans ces dans ces manières de
s'exprimer et bon il n'était pas mis
partout tout le monde il faut dire la
vérité il avait une réputation d'homme
autoritaire un peu crâneur qui roulait
un peu les mécaniques voilà ça il avait
cette réputation là c'était quelqu'un
qui avait pas un caractère facile même
son épouse le dit d'ailleurs
un homme colérique mais les enquêteurs
apprennent vite qu'aucune plainte n'a
jamais été déposée contre lui
comme il est d'usage les policiers
s'intéressent alors à sa vie conjugale
avec sa femme Michel ils sont mariés
depuis 10 ans elle le décrit comme un
mari modèle le raconte que il venait lui
apporter le petit déjeuner tous les
matins au lit il lui fait ses dernières
heures elle avait droit à un bouquet de
fleurs chaque fois c'était son
anniversaire ou une anniversaire du
mariage etc il était très prévenant à
son égard c'était un gentil Marie la
veuve est longuement entendu au
commissariat
on va lui poser des questions qui font
très mal voilà les questions sur
avez-vous une assurance vie
votre aviez-vous des problèmes conjugaux
votre sexualité avec Monsieur pourrielle
était-elle normal votre couple peut
fonctionner est-il bien que savez-vous
de du passé de votre mari que savez-vous
de ce qu'il fait dans la journée quelles
questions qui sont très indiscrètes et
qui touchent à l'intimité mais les
conclusions s'imposent bientôt
le couple s'entendait bien donc c'est
une porte qui se referme tout a été
vérifié elle n'avait aucun intérêt à
faire disparaître son mari
seulement lorsqu'elle va apprendre que
son époux se rendait deux fois par
semaine dans un section Michel va tomber
des nues
[Musique]
c'est un élément qui qui était ignoré
par son épouse bien sûr il avait caché
absolument
cette partie de sa vie à sa femme elle
se posait pas de question sur ce que
faisait son mari dans la journée
d'autant qu'ils avaient une sexualité
d'après ce qu'elle dit absolument normal
et ce n'est pas la seule surprise de ce
dossier car la victime a plusieurs zones
d'ombre dans sa vie
lors de leurs auditions les policiers
découvrent que Guy pour Yelle avait ses
habitudes dans un bar de Cavaillon
l'embuscade où il jouait souvent au
poker le meurtre serait-il lié à une
dette de jeu
Cavaillon est connu pour une ville à
l'époque où il se jouait beaucoup
d'argent en carte
notamment dans certains établissements
et la police va envisager une une dette
de jeu une embrouille qui aurait pu
avoir lieu dans dans le bar
alors les policiers vont entendre tous
les habitués qui jouaient avec gituriel
il y a des une table ou deux personnes à
la retraite qui viennent faire leur
partie de cartes mais bon on joue quoi
on joue au café quoi le café ou
l'apéritif si la partie se termine vers
midi quoi c'était vraiment quelque chose
d'amical derrière ce que disent en fait
la plupart des gens qui viennent
régulièrement celui qui perd va payer le
café les enquêteurs très rapidement ça
en fait qu'il y a des parties qui sont
financièrement intéressantes plusieurs
centaines d'euros donc sont joués sur
certaines parties joueurs de poker assis
du oui mais les enquêteurs constatent
que Guy pourriel n'avait contracté
aucune tête de jeu
[Musique]
très vite les policiers réorientent
l'enquête sur les lieux du drame pour
une raison très simple la police locale
leur signale qu'une semaine jour pour
jour avant le meurtre de Guy pour yell
le sexy de la galerie terradou a été
braqué
[Musique]
le responsable avait été menacé par deux
individus à une semaine d'intervalle
deux événements liés aux sex-shop ça
paraît effectivement un petit peu
suspect donc il y a eu une piste aussi
de ce côté-là qui
s'ouvre-t-il été témoin de ce hold-up
les braqueurs ont-ils décidé de
l'éliminer
le gérant du secteur est à nouveau
entendu mais l'homme est formel Guy
pourriel n'était pas là le jour de
l'agression
à Avignon les policiers commencent à
douter
[Musique]
au fur et à mesure que l'enquête de la
police judiciaire avance on se rend
compte que c'est un homme la victime est
un homme sans problème on a un petit peu
de mal à comprendre ce qui a pu se
passer sur un homme comme tout le monde
c'est désespérément banal et on avait du
mal à accrocher
à faire le lien entre cette vie paisible
et puis cette fin dramatique
après une semaine d'enquête les
policiers ont épuisé toutes les pistes
pour la police l'énigme reste entière
heureusement un témoignage inespéré va
relancer les investigations
un garagiste se présente au commissariat
d'Avignon il a reconnu la photo de Guy
pourriez dans le journal et il a des
révélations à faire le petit jeune les
enquêteurs donc
entendre un garagiste qui a vu Guy
pourriez le 2 jours avant le meurtre et
guipouriel est venu dans ce dans ce
garage automobile pour faire réparer son
pneu qui était crevé et le garagiste
comme son salarié disent à Guy pourriel
mais votre pneu
il est pas c'est pas un clou qui
rentrait dans le pneu c'est quelqu'un
qui la taille Adé volontairement un pneu
crevé deux jours avant d'être abattu
pour les policiers il ne s'agit
certainement pas d'une coïncidence
était un avertissement une menace
les enquêteurs interrogent une nouvelle
fois Michel la veuve de la victime
elle le raconte alors une anecdote
troublante
un jour à la pêche son mari s'était fait
violemment à cause de par un inconnu
sans aucune raison apparente
il avait dit à sa femme j'ai fait une je
me suis fait accoster je suis pas
tranquille et c'est à cette occasion là
d'ailleurs que monsieur pourrielle avait
cherché à acheter une arme quelqu'un qui
qui s'est senti menacé à un moment donné
qui cherche à négocier l'achat d'une
arme on va essayer de retrouver qui
aurait pu être l'individu qu'il avait
accosté à la pêche
mais qui est cette personne qui
effrayait Tanguy pourriel
Michel l'ignore pourtant en reprenant
les auditions des proches de la victime
les enquêteurs vont découvrir que la vie
du retraité cachée encore d'autres zones
d'ombre
[Applaudissements]
en paisible retraités Guy pour y aller
pour habitude d'aller pêcher tous les
après-midi sur les berges de la Durance
si la victime affectionnée
particulièrement cette activité de plein
air les enquêteurs s'interrogent sur
d'autres motivations éventuelles
c'est un lieu qui est fréquenté par la
communauté homosexuelle
sex-shop Durance tout de suite on pense
que possède l'orée de mauvaise rencontre
il aurait pu être témoin de quelque
chose le bord de Durance ils ont une
réputation et ça peut être des
rencontres moues ça peut être
des échanges ça peut être n'importe quoi
donc là l'imagination
section pédant les fantasmes on va dire
on y faire on peut tout imaginer
Guy pourriel allait-il réellement pêcher
lorsqu'il se rendait sur les bords de la
Durance ou venait-il pour y faire des
rencontres
les policiers décident de mettre
l'endroit sous surveillance il se
demande si le meurtrier ne fait pas
partie des habitués de ce lieu de
rendez-vous ils vont entendre à la fois
les pêcheurs le jour les libertins la
nuit et ça malheureusement nous donnera
rien aucun couple échangiste entendu sur
place ne peut apporter l'ombre d'une
information intéressante
après plusieurs semaines de recherches
l'enquête sur le décès de Guy pouriel
est au point mort
en désespoir de cause les enquêteurs
décident alors de lancer un appel à
témoin dans la presse
le but de cet appel à témoin c'est de
trouver quelqu'un qui a vu le tueur
parti une fois qu'il est sorti parking
on s'est absolument pas par où il est
passé on sait pas qui s'il a utilisé un
moyen de transport si après une moto une
voiture
au bout d'une semaine seulement l'appel
à témoin porte ses fruits
plusieurs personnes habitant à proximité
du centre commercial appelle la police
[Musique]
il y a deux témoignages qui vont
intéresser la police judiciaire le
témoignage d'une d'une personne qui
habite à 300 400 mètres de la scène de
crime qui explique donc aux policiers
que le 11 décembre 2003 vers 17h qu'en
bas de chez elle il y a un véhicule
utilitaire blanc un véhicule aperçu
quelques minutes seulement après le
drame un conducteur qui démarre en
trombe
le témoin suspicieux n'a retenu que
quelques chiffres de la plaque
minéralogique et puis un autre témoin
donne à peu près la même description de
la camionnette il ajoute même que sur le
flanc de la camionnette il y a une sorte
d'autocollant sombre noire qui
représente un plongeur sous-marin
ce second témoin donne également
certains chiffres de l'immatriculation
du coup les policiers n'ont pas le choix
que de reprendre un travail très
fastidieux qui consiste à interroger le
terminal des cartes grises et de
ressortir toutes les fourgonnettes
blanches qui pourraient avoir une bride
de numéro qui correspondent à des
numéros relevés par les témoins après
plusieurs semaines de recherche le
travail des hommes de l'APJ va payer ils
vont établir une liste d'une quinzaine
de véhicules blancs suspects
et systématiquement ils vont appeler les
propriétaires pour savoir s'ils ont
toujours la voiture ce qui et puis
vérifier leur emploi du temps aux
besoins arrivés à la fin de la liste
seul une voiture pourrait correspondre
par élimination en retient une notamment
on va entendre le propriétaire enfin en
tout cas le titulaire de la carte grise
tu prétends en fait qu'il l'a vendu dans
le Gard dans une ville qui s'appelle
Marguerite il explique que ça c'est fait
un rond-point dans des circonstances un
petit peu particulière
il ne connaît pas
l'identité donc de l'acquéreur qu'il
décrit parlant d'un type assez jeune
d'un mètre 80 à ses mains ça qui
pourrait correspondre au profil du tueur
les policiers sont un peu suspicieux sur
sa sur ces déclarations ils vont
l'interroger ils vont essayer d'en
savoir un petit peu plus sur ce sur ce
curieux vendeur et surtout a-t-il
vraiment vendu ce véhicule où est-il
est-il l'homme qui peut être a pu a pu
tuer Guy pour y aller
il y a bien un moyen de vérifier que la
transaction a eu lieu par exemple si
l'acheteur a payé par chèque ou par
virement bancaire
le problème c'est qu'il a réglé en
espèces et qu'ils ont rempli des papiers
mais qu'il n'en n'a pas gardé double et
que visiblement l'autre enfin
l'acquéreur n'a pas fait immatriculer
cette camionnette donc il roule toujours
sous le nom de l'ancien propriétaire
mais heureusement pour lui le vendeur va
se souvenir in extremis d'une
information a priori anecdotique pendant
la transaction
l'acheteur a reçu un coup de téléphone
sur son portable grâce au Relais des
réseaux de téléphones mobiles les
policiers liste tous les téléphones
portables présents dans le périmètre du
rond-point le jour de la vente alors
exactement
et là les policiers sortent une dizaine
une quinzaine de numéros de téléphone
les intéressent pour la première fois
depuis le meurtre une piste solide
apparaît le numéro de l'acheteur fait-il
partie de cette liste et si c'est le cas
l'homme a-t-il un lien avec le meurtre
pour le savoir les policiers comparent
ces 15 numéros à la liste de tous les
téléphones utilisés au moment exact du
meurtre aux abords de la galerie
commerciale du terradou et la bingo il y
en a un seul numéro correspond c'est
celui d'un homme de 34 ans un certain
Éric zagago Zago ce nom interpelle les
enquêteurs
les policiers se disent tient ce nom on
le connaît
les policiers font le lien
avec un nommézago Fernand fernandago
c'est le propriétaire de l'embuscade le
bar ou gituriel avait l'habitude de
jouer aux cartes et donc à partir de là
on se dit qu'il y a peut-être quelque
chose là à creuser puisqu'on retrouve le
nom de Zago à deux reprises
Fernand Zago et le père d'Éric Zago
l'individu soupçonné d'être le meurtrier
du terreau mais pourquoi
Eric le fils aurait-il tué un client du
bar familial
[Musique]
dans un premier temps les enquêteurs
constatent que le jeune homme est un
individu des plus ordinaires
il est ramoneur de professions il est
séparé de sa compagne il a un petit
enfant il est retourné sa grand-mère qui
habite à Marguerite il a son père qui
est un ancien international de rugby il
a son frère et sa sœur qui tous les deux
ont plutôt bien réussi dans la vie dans
leur existence et lui en réalité c'est
un peu un looser mais ça en fait pas
pour autant un criminel le seul point
commun entre la victime et
Eric Zago c'est l'embuscade le bar tenu
par son père un bar ou eric a travaillé
et où il aurait pu croiser la victime
[Musique]
Eric Zago travaillait très régulièrement
pour son père au bar de l'embuscade et
travailler il y a très longtemps il n'y
travaille plus du tout
Éric Zago semble de plus en plus suspect
mais les enquêteurs ne disposent encore
d'aucun mobile
alors il décide de mettre le jeune homme
sous surveillance mais
Eric Zago en surveillance discrète pour
essayer de voir un petit peu son emploi
du temps ses habitudes
on n'a pas d'éléments enfin c'est
quelqu'un qui peut avoir quelque chose à
faire dans ce qui est arrivé à Monsieur
pouriel
les policiers n'ont qu'une seule
solution attendre et c'est par pur
hasard que quelques semaines plus tard
l'affaire va rebondir
nous sommes le 6 février 2004 2 mois
après le meurtre de Guy pour hier à
rodilian près de Nîmes il est 22h
les gendarmes patrouillent et remarquent
un véhicule feu éteint stationné en race
campagne au milieu de nulle part
le conducteur est au volant
les gendarmes lui demandent alors de
descendre du véhicule
on retrouve dans la voiture
des objets étonnants sur le siège avant
passager les gendarmes découvrent un
revolver une cagoule des fausses plaques
d'immatriculation et un masque de Zorro
il contrôle cet individu il s'appelle
Éric Zago
on appelant le central les gendarmes ne
tarde pas à découvrir kerhexago fait
l'objet d'une surveillance policière
dans les heures qui suivent l'homme
interpellé est livré à la police
judiciaire d'Avignon
le sol élément dont on dispose c'est
l'arme retrouvée en possession de des
Hexago et possiblement l'arme qui a tué
Guy pourrielle on n'a pas encore les
résultats de la balistique mais en tout
cas c'est du 9 mm qui a tué Guy pourriel
et l'arme est un osmm donc a priori il y
a quand même de fortes chances que ça
puisse que ça puisse coller une arme du
même calibre que celle du meurtre un
téléphone localisé sur les lieux du
crime et une voiture
identique à celle du tueur
pour les policiers il est fort probable
qu'Eric Zago soit impliqué dans le
meurtre de Guy pour yell reste à savoir
comment et surtout pourquoi
interroger le suspect ni tout
implication
Éric Zago et ferme oui je connais Guy
pour yell c'est un client du barre de
mon père mais non je n'ai pas exécuté et
non je ne suis pas l'auteur ou le
commanditaire ou l'exécutant de de cette
assassinat on l'entend on l'entend et
puis ça me donnerait
donc les heures passent et on a toujours
pas plus d'éléments les heures
d'interrogatoire défilent face aux
mutisme du suspect le juge d'instruction
décide de prolonger la garde à vue c'est
une guerre d'usure qui s'engage
[Musique]
après 36 heures de garde à vue
Eric Zago finit par craquer
Eric Zago affirme
donc au bout de 36 heures de garde à vue
qu'il est bien l'auteur de cette
assassinat
Eric Zago revendique le crime en disant
oui c'est moi c'est moi qui l'ai tué
c'est moi qui ai tué Guy pour y aller
et il a l'air assez fier de lui assez
content de lui assez satisfait de lui
en 36 heures il a rien voulu savoir et
puis d'un seul coup pour des raisons qui
nous échappent totalement il se met à
clamer sa culpabilité
Eric Zago ne se contente pas d'avouer le
meurtre il raconte même qu'il a tenté
d'éliminer Guy pour rien à plusieurs
reprises par le passé
une après-midi quelques
8 10 jours avant son
ultime passage à l'acte il a repéré Guy
pourriel dans le jardin qui est en train
de bricoler il est lui caché derrière la
haie il a déjà cet arme avec lui et il
va renoncer à son projet d'assassinat
parce qu'il considère qu'il est trop
loin et que si l'enjambe à elle l'autre
va le voir et va prendre forcément la
suite la deuxième tentative c'était sur
le parking du terradou le 9 décembre
2003 alors que gippouriel était au sex
shop
Eric Zago lui a crevé un pneu pour
l'obliger à sortir de son véhicule
il voulait passer à l'acte ce jour là il
a crevé les pneus en pensant que il
allait sortir de sa voiture et que pour
y aller sortir de sa voiture sa
genouillée qu'il pourrait le tuer
facilement à ce moment-là le problème
c'est que pour rien n'est pas sorti de
la voiture et qu'il a été directement au
garage donc il n'a pas pu le tuer
l'homme ne renonce pas deux jours plus
tard il repasse à l'action plus
déterminé que jamais et là il est dans
cette fameuse galerie
il va faire même un repérage il arrive
un petit peu avant sur les lieux du sur
les lieux du crime c'est là où il va
être vu par le boulanger
Eric zagour raconte qu'il a ensuite
attendu le vieil homme devant le sex
shop
et à un moment donné il enfonce sa
cagoule de manière à dissimuler son
visage il va se coller derrière Guy
Pourrières il va tirer une première fois
il va le rater et une deuxième fois il
va l'abattre d'une seule et unique
derrière moi
pour vérifier la version donnée par Eric
Zago les policiers font venir au
commissariat René bagnoles le boulanger
témoin d'humeurtre ils veulent voir s'il
reconnaît l'homme aperçu devant la
galerie un quart d'heure avant les coups
de feu
on rentre donc tu as une pièce avec une
glace sans terre et on nous demande de
voir si on reconnaît la personne qu'on
avait vu au mois de décembre tirer sur
l'autre là au milieu des suspects un
homme souriait étrangement c'est Éric
zagago René le reconnaît aussitôt
pratiquement on aurait dit qu'il était
content de ce trophée il y a un
revendiquant non non mais c'est moi il y
a pas de souci
mais bon la physionomie générale sa
corpulence je leur dis bon
j'ai de grosses après somption sur cette
personne là voilà
reconnu par le boulanger le suspect
semble fier de son acte les hommes de
l'APJ ne comprennent pas son attitude et
une question leur brûle les lèvres
pourquoi ca bien pu faire guipouriel
pour être abattu à bout portant par et
Rick Zago
au moment où le meurtrier présumé leur
dévoile son mobile les policiers n'en
reviennent pas
c'était la première fois que j'avais une
affaire crime de sang avec un mobile
pareil
[Musique]
Eric Zago va leur raconter une histoire
que les policiers ne parviennent pas à
croire
une histoire qui selon Eric Zago a
commencé 17 ans plus tôt c'était en 1986
il raconte à la grande stupeur de la
police judiciaire que 17 ans à 20 alors
qu'il était adolescent et qu'il servit
de façon régulière donc au bar de son
père Guy pour rien lui aurait dit petit
dépêche-toi sers-moi sinon tu prends de
gifle
Hexago enfin tout cas c'est ce qu'il
expliquait elle n'est pas appréciée
cette humiliation et revendique son acte
en disant il m'a humilié il fallait il
fallait que je lave la France Guy
pourriel serait donc mort à cause d'une
simple phrase prononcée 17 ans plus tôt
l'histoire semble un vrai semblable
à la rédaction candide ça y est qu'on
annonce le mobile de ce meurtre personne
n'y croit
carpentera la police vient d'élucider un
crime étrange un homme de 72 ans avait
été abattu il y a deux mois le meurtrier
présumé a reconnu l'effet et le mobile a
stupéfié les policiers la victime aurait
été visée en raison d'une remarque
désagréable faite 17 ans plus tôt
l'histoire fait la une des journaux et
tout le monde dans la région a du mal à
y croire
du côté de Cavaillon c'est
l'incompréhension la plus totale de
nombreux habitants connaissaient Éric
Zago depuis son plus jeune âge
c'est une grosse stupéfaction parce que
Eric c'est un gamin que j'ai reçu même
chez moi parce qu'il était il a l'âge de
mon fils aîné et donc il venait s'amuser
à la maison je connais la famille quoi
c'est une famille tout à fait tout à
fait normale tout à fait il y a rien
d'extraordinaire jamais je pouvais
penser que ce gamin pouvait en arriver à
cette extrémité quoi pour les enquêteurs
tout semble bien accusé Éric Zago sauf
son mobile auquel il ne croit pas le
juge d'instruction leur demande de
vérifier cette histoire à hurissante
de toute la famille j'étais pas
spécialement convaincu de la réalité du
mobile qui l'invoquait il y aurait eu
des fêtes il y aurait une bagarre il y
aurait quelque chose là je m'en serais
je m'en serais souvenu là une parole non
je m'en souviens pas quoi je veux dire à
la limite ça m'étonne pas de Guy parce
que c'est vraiment dans son genre de
caractère mais je pense pas que je pense
je pense me souviens pas d'y avoir
assisté cette phrase prononcée par
giturielle et qui a tant marqué erizago
n'a marqué que lui parce que personne
tellement elle est futile ne s'en
souvient absolument personne pourtant
Eric Zago persiste et signe et il va
même plus loin il affirme que Guy pour
rien ne lui a pas laissé le choix il
raconte comment deux mois avant le
meurtre il a décidé de rencontrer le
retraité pour s'expliquer et pour
obtenir des excuses
il frappe au domicile de Guy pour rien
puisqu'il a retrouvé le domicile dit
pourriel ouvre
Éric Zago lui raconte son histoire il
aurait alors répété au vieil homme sa
phrase vexante prononcée 17 ans plus tôt
au bar de son père pour lui cette phrase
est à l'origine de tous ces malheurs
tout est de la faute de cette incidence
tout tous ces échecs viennent de cette
humiliation suprême dans son parcours
professionnel il va aller des chèques en
échec il va faire des petits boulots il
va il va se marier mais il va très vite
divorcer selon
Eric Zago le retraité serait resté
complètement insensible face à son
désarroi
qu'est-ce que tu racontes petit mais je
me souviens pas de ça tu racontes
n'importe quoi tu délires je vous dis
que c'est vrai je vous demande des
excuses mais enfin arrête tu m'ennuies
là tu me fatigues dégage et j'ai pas
d'excuses à te donner voilà et Eric
zagol aspire raconte cette discussion il
dit non non mais pour y aller rester
correct simplement très froid très
distant et il a pas voulu me présenter
des excuses et je me suis dit que là il
ne s'en sortirait pas comme ça
guitoriel ne présentera pas ses excuses
et rentrera chez lui comme si de rien
n'était c'est à cet instant précis Kerry
Zago aurait décidé de se venger
à partir de ce moment là voyant qu'aucun
aucune discussion n'était possible pour
laver la front il va décider de suivre
cet homme il va les pieds pendant un
mois Éric Zago presque tous les jours
suivre
10 courriel va le suivre à la pêche il
va le suivre donc il connaît ses
habitudes il connaît les habitudes du
retraité il va le suivre au section il
va le suivre aux différents bars où il
se rendent tous les jours en
interrogatoire zagour raconte que c'est
à ce moment-là qu'il a acheté l'arme
pour passer à l'acte
cet arme a une particularité lorsqu'il
l'achète elle est équipée de 5 balles 5
munitions ensuite
Eric Zago va vérifier le fonctionnement
de cette arme et il va aller s'isoler
dans une forêt et il va tirer trois
projectiles il me reste plus que deux
balles qui serviront à tuer Guy pour
yell pour une menace de 2 chiffres
[Musique]
encore une fois les enquêteurs sont face
à un dilemme car rien ne vient prouver
le récit de Zago une question se pose
sont-ils face aux délires d'un homme
complètement déséquilibré le juge
ordonne alors une expertise
psychiatrique les conclusions sont
édifiantes il souffre d'une psychose
paranoïaque délirante le psychiatre
considère qu'il y a abolition de son
discernement c'est-à-dire qu'il n'est
pas responsable de ses actes
pour l'expert René pan Delon pas de
doute
Eric zagour raconte sa vérité
ça m'a quoi dire ça m'a détruit ça a été
abominable pour moi pendant des années
tous ce qui m'est arrivé un petit peu de
difficile de compliquer dans la vie
c'est parce que au départ j'ai été
détruit par cette parole il dit j'ai
passé des années à essayer de me
reconstruire au fil de ma vie et puis
cette reconstruction a toujours buté sur
ce cette insulte de départ et je n'avais
plus d'autre solution que d'éliminer la
personne qui avait proférée cette cette
insulte qui m'avait détruite
face au psychiatre Éric Zago va faire la
démonstration de son délire paranoïaque
car le suspect obéit à une logique pour
le moins déconcertante
il me dit à la fin j'ai pris une feuille
de papier et j'ai fait deux colonnes sur
une colonne j'ai mis les raisons pour
lesquelles je ne dois pas
éliminer tu es la victime et donc là il
avait mis la victime est âgée
je suis contre la peine de mort j'ai
jamais fait de mal à personne même pas
un animal et de l'autre côté il a émis
17 ans de souffrance
il a dit c'est ce qui a fait basculer ma
décision
pour l'expert
Eric Zago n'est pas responsable de ses
actes et dans ce cas il échappera aux
griffes de la justice mais à la surprise
générale quand le meurtrier présumait la
prend il est fou de rage ce qui se
comprend moins en tout cas ce qui est
moins habituel c'est la réaction des
Hexago qui n'accepte pas d'être
considéré comme fou pour parler
simplement
et qui veut une contre expertise parce
qu'il veut être jugé
la contre expertise parle d'une
altération du discernement il parle
uniquement d'altération en clair ça veut
dire qu'il est parfaitement accessible à
une sanction pénale et qu'il va être
jugé qu'il va avoir un procès devant la
Cour d'Assise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes le 13 mars 2006 le procès
d'Eric Zago s'ouvre devant la Cour
d'assis du Vaucluse à Avignon la salle
est comble tout le monde veut voir celui
qui aurait tué un homme pour une simple
menace de gifle vieille de 17 ans mais
l'accusé surprend depuis son box il
semble tout à fait normal
Eric Zago est quelqu'un qui
d'apparence est plutôt un garçon costaud
bien rasé porte il porte bien sur lui il
a un costume il présente bien comme on
dit il a pas de signes extérieur de
maladie mentale il donne le change sans
aucun doute cette impression ne durera
pas longtemps dès qu'il s'explique sur
les faits les réponses qu'il donne
jettent un froid dans la salle
[Musique]
il explique sans aucun état d'âme sans
aucun remords ce qu'il a fait comment il
a préparé et est-ce qu'il a fait
exactement et il le dit de manière si
simple que c'est ça qui était effrayant
on est dans une revendication
qui est posée par par l'accusé qui qui
vient dire j'ai commis cet axe je
regrette pas il le méritait
et ça ça heurte c'est insupportable
rapidement dans la salle tout le monde
se pose encore et toujours la même
question et Rick Zago est-il fou
on perçoit le caractère pathologique de
ses propos et puis il y a un peu
indicible une sorte de distance de
froideur
les gens n'existent pas quoi on perçoit
cette cette folie une folie qu'on peut
notamment constater son frère et sa
soeur venus témoigner à la barre on
découvre qui tourne pas bien rond quand
même un type qui reste enfermé pendant
un an chez lui et qui ne sortait que la
nuit et encore quand il sortait c'était
en tenue de ski
c'est pas complètement rien quoi
[Musique]
et les jurés ne sont pas au bout de leur
surprise les experts psychiatront une
autre interprétation du crime
en tuant
Éric Zago a voulu régler ses comptes
avec son père
c'était un garçon probablement sensible
Éric zagot avec un père qui était dur
comme comme le fer et qui ne supportait
pas les faiblesses de son fils qui est
certaine c'est quasiment certain c'est
que pour rien le ressembler au père de
d'Éric Zago ils avaient la même
personnalité la même carrure bon c'était
des rubismènes tous les deux la même
carrure le même temps cassant
autoritaire humiliant et je pense que à
un moment donné
Eric Zago a complètement disjoncté pour
ça clairement Eric Zago fait une sorte
de confusion entre guilleur et son père
en gros en tuant guipuriel il a un peu
tué son père
la cause semble entendu quand soudain
Éric Zago fait une incroyable
déclaration
[Musique]
je ne suis pas l'auteur c'est pas moi
qui l'ai tué
en fait c'est pas moi c'est la base
et il part dans une théorie sur les
balles et là tout le monde est sidéré
c'est à dire que là il est manifestement
dans l'incohérence totale après trois
jours de débat au moment des plaidoiries
l'accusé donne des consignes très
strictes à ses avocats il leur interdit
de plaider la folie
qui ne sont complètement muselés par
leurs clients qui
leur interdit de s'exprimer en leur
disant mais non je ne veux pas que vous
vous évoquiez ma folie je suis
responsable je suis coupable je ne
regrette rien
dans son réquisitoire l'avocat général
requiert 11 années de prison
les magistrats et les jurés quitte la
salle pour délibérer
[Musique]
après à peine trois heures ils sont de
retour pour l'énoncé du verdict
la présidente prend son micro et dit
donc elle répond oui aux questions sur
la culpabilité sur la préméditation donc
on s'attend à maximum 20 ans et là c'est
la stupéfaction le verdict tombe contre
tout attente Éric Zago et condamné à
seulement 2 ans de prison avec
internement d'office pour les jurés
l'homme est fou de tout évidence dans la
salle d'audience c'est la stupeur
c'est absolument une peine
d'emprisonnement de deux ans pour pour
quelqu'un qui est déclaré coupable
d'assassinat c'est à dire coupable
d'avoir tué avec préméditation ça ne
s'est jamais vu et du coup au lieu
d'aller en prison Eric Zago s'est
retrouvé à l'hôpital psychiatrique
c'est-à-dire juste là où il voulait pas
aller il est fou furieux il ne quand il
a entendu la présidente dire qu'elle
leur donnait d'office en hospitalisation
ça a été une colère noire
à l'issue de l'audience
Eric Zago est transféré au centre
psychiatrique de Montfavet dans l'unité
des malades difficiles il fait appel de
sa condamnation et change d'avocat
[Musique]
21 mars 2007 le procès en appel s'ouvre
à Nîmes cette fois-ci
Eric Zago n'a qu'un but évitez
l'internement en hôpital psychiatrique
sa nouvelle avocate à interdiction
formelle d'évoquer sa folie pendant les
débats
il m'explique qu'il est prêt peu importe
la peine à prendre et accepter n'importe
quel peine que ce soit une dix ans 12
ans ou 14 ans tant qu'on ne le soigne
pas tant qu'on ne l'oblige pas à se
soigner c'est la seule volonté qu'il a
hirexago a changé il n'a plus se regard
fou on sent qu'il a fait une qu'il suit
une psychothérapie que il évolue au lieu
de dire froidement comme il le disait à
Avignon je voulais le tuer je l'ai le
tuer il dit je voulais laver
l'humiliation mais je ne voulais pas sa
mort parce qu'il demande de manière très
énergique c'est je suis coupable je suis
responsable de ce que j'ai fait je
mérite une sanction je le sais et je
l'accepte
à la fin des débats l'avocat général
requiert une peine de 12 ans de prison
après deux heures de délibérer le
verdict tombe
Eric Zago est condamné à 14 années de
détention c'est plus que leur
acquisition et jusqu'à la dernière
minute l'accusé des concerts jurés et
avocat
je me retourne je m'attendais à une
réaction de sa goût ou de colère ou
d'abattement et pas du tout pas du tout
et je m'aperçois que c'est pire que ça
c'est pas que ça glisse et que c'est pas
grave c'est qu'il est content il est
content et la seule question qui m'a
posé c'est est-ce que je suis obligée de
prendre mes médicaments encore est-ce
qu'on va m'obliger à faire des soins je
réponds j'ai pas le choix je lui dis non
non vous êtes un adulte vous choisissez
si vous voulez faire des soins ou pas
vous êtes en prison
[Musique]
Eric Zago a été incarcéré dans le sud de
la France il a déjà purgé plus de la
moitié de sa peine il pourrait dès
aujourd'hui bénéficier d'une libération
conditionnelle
[Musique]